Transcription: eric vautier
Relecteur: Claire Ghyselen
Je suis très heureux de vous retrouver
aujourd’hui à EM Lyon,
alors qu’il y a cinq ans de cela,
je ne connaissais pas du tout
l’univers des grandes écoles.
J'aspirais, comme beaucoup de jeunes
garçons, à être footballeur professionnel,
voire de e-sport, ou encore à reprendre
l’exploitation agricole de mon oncle.
Pourtant, le chemin que j’ai pris
aujourd’hui est tout autre
et m’a permis de créer
un groupe média de référence
dans le domaine
de l’enseignement supérieur,
rassemblant quotidiennement plusieurs
dizaines de milliers d’étudiants,
des dizaines de collaborateurs
à temps plein,
des centaines de freelances,
neuf entreprises.
Ma première entreprise, Mister prépa,
a été créée il y a plus de 3,5 ans,
alors qu’avant le baccalauréat,
je ne connaissais pas la classe prépa.
Ce qui a fait que j'ai réussi, c'est non
seulement le fait d'avoir fait des choix,
mais surtout d'avoir cru en ces derniers,
en mes capacités.
Ça demande beaucoup de travail :
un travail personnel
pour bien se connaître,
évoluer, se challenger,
se remettre en question
et un travail collectif
pour s’entourer des bonnes personnes
et faire briller chacune d’entre elles.
Mais comment j'en suis arrivé là ?
Je vais vous raconter
les différentes étapes de ma vie,
les rencontres qui m’ont bouleversé,
les chemins que j’ai pris
ou que j’ai esquivés,
les raccourcis qui m’ont propulsé
et ceux qui auraient pu me faire échouer.
En bref,
vous montrer que tout est possible
à qui se donne les moyens de réussir.
Initialement, comme je vous l’ai expliqué,
je suis issu d’un milieu modeste.
Je pensais naïvement
que mon chemin était tout tracé.
Agrémenté d’un peu d’autocensure,
je n’avais finalement que très peu
de perspectives pour mon futur.
Puis un jour,
un professeur de terminale me présente,
me conseille, me pousse
vers la classe prépa.
Voie méconnue,
je décide de m’y intéresser.
Ça m'intrigue un petit peu.
Mon objectif à la base,
c’était d’avoir le baccalauréat.
Donc ce n’était que du bonus.
Puis je me suis dit :
« Après tout, faire carrière dans le foot,
si j’ai les ligaments croisés,
c’est fini. »
Alors que faire une amnésie,
c’était plus complexe.
Je me suis donc orienté vers ce chemin
sinueux, complexe de la prépa.
On est jeune, on n’a pas la maturité.
Il y a des exigences, des attentes
qui sont très élevées.
Concrètement, on se prend une claque.
L’intensité de cette dernière varie
en fonction de la préparation
et de la connaissance
que l’on a de la filière en amont.
Je vous laisse donc imaginer
la claque que je me suis prise.
C'était catastrophique,
cataclysmique même.
À tel point que ma professeure
principale me convoque
seulement deux mois
après le début de la prépa
pour m’expliquer
que je n’étais pas un bon profil,
que je n’allais pas durer
et qu’au prochain semestre,
j’allais devoir me réorienter,
que je n’étais pas rigoureux.
Ça a été un déclic.
Un déclic où dans ce chemin
à sens unique de la prépa,
je me retrouve confronté
à un obstacle, mais je me relève.
Et à ce moment-là,
j’ai deux possibilités :
soit regarder derrière moi mon passé
et me dire :
« Finalement, je retourne sur mes pas
pour essayer de trouver
un chemin plus accessible. »
Mais ce n'est pas ce que j'ai fait.
Reculer, c'est renoncer.
C’est perdre du temps, perdre la ressource
la plus précieuse dans notre monde.
J'ai donc décidé d'avancer.
D’avancer vers ce chemin
que je ne maîtrisais pas,
pour essayer de mieux l’appréhender,
de mieux me l’approprier.
Je savais qu’en avançant,
progressivement, j’allais accélérer,
j’allais capter les attentes.
Et c’est ce qui s’est passé.
Alors que quelques mois auparavant,
je ne connaissais pas la classe prépa,
je termine major de ma promotion
et j’intègre EM Lyon.
EM Lyon justement, l’école des
entrepreneurs, des early makers.
Mon rêve ?
Absolument pas.
Pour moi, être entrepreneur impliquait
d'avoir beaucoup d'argent à la base.
Tout ce que je n'avais pas.
Je me rappelle même d’ailleurs à
mon jury d’admission - une salle là-bas -
la question : « Quel type
d’entrepreneur souhaitez-vous être ? »
Plutôt : « Quel type
J’ai répondu, au risque de vous décevoir :
« Je ne veux pas du tout
être entrepreneur. »
C’est pourquoi, et en toute logique,
seulement un mois et demi après,
en juillet 2019,
je me lance dans Mister Prépa.
L’objectif à la base n’était pas
de créer une entreprise,
c’était de créer un collectif d’étudiants
soucieux de transmettre, de partager,
de contribuer à l’égalité des chances
à l’échelle nationale.
De permettre aux étudiants
de mieux appréhender les concours
et de découvrir les grandes écoles.
Très rapidement, notre positionnement
assez unique, disrupteur,
nous a permis
d’avoir une audience significative
avec une croissance
mensuelle à trois chiffres.
Des écoles décident de nous contacter.
Elles veulent devenir partenaires,
sont prêtes à investir chez nous.
On crée donc l’entreprise
quelques mois après,
début de l’aventure entrepreneuriale
alors que je ne voulais pas du tout
être entrepreneur.
Notre succès à ce moment-là, nos forces,
inégalées par rapport
aux acteurs de l’écosystème
étaient pourtant très simples,
basiques dirait Orelsan :
une audience présente
avec qui on a une relation informelle,
une disponibilité constante sept jours sur
sept, un renouvellement assidu du contenu,
une parfaite maîtrise
des nouveaux réseaux sociaux
comme TikTok, Discord,
Snapchat, Instagram.
Et parallèlement à ça, je commence
ma première année à l’EM
et je découvre ce qu’est le droit,
la comptabilité, le marketing, la finance.
Je m'aperçois que tout me plaît bien.
C’est à ce moment précis que je fais deux
constats au sujet de l’entrepreneuriat.
Premièrement, pour être entrepreneur,
il faut être bon partout,
mais expert dans un seul
et unique domaine.
Deuxièmement,
pour faire de l’entrepreneuriat,
l’argent n’est pas nécessaire.
Mais il faut répondre à un vrai besoin,
solutionner un problème,
et ça demande du temps et de l’engagement.
Un engagement qui se veut être
à différentes échelles.
Dans mon cas, un engagement envers
les étudiants qui sont présents, fidèles,
et qui attendent un renouvellement
du contenu, des informations.
Un engagement envers nos partenaires
qui nous financent, qui investissent, qui
attendent un retour sur investissement.
Un engagement envers nos collaborateurs
qui sont présents,
qui se donnent corps et âme
pour le développement du projet
et qui attendent une rémunération,
une reconnaissance,
un sentiment d’appartenance,
mais surtout un engagement
envers nous-mêmes.
Lorsqu’on lance un projet,
c’est un peu comme notre bébé,
c’est une extension de nous-mêmes.
Et au moment où on a compris ça,
on adopte un rythme de croisière.
Mister Prépa commence à se développer.
Mars 2020 : confinement.
En période de crise, qu’on
peut d’ailleurs assimiler à un tsunami,
il y a deux postures à adopter :
soit la posture de la personne
qui ne va rien faire
et qui va se laisser absorber,
aspirer par la vague,
qui ne sera plus maître du chemin choisi,
ou ceux qui vont surfer sur la vague
et qui vont réussir à avoir une vue
dégagée pour prendre le bon chemin.
C’est ce qu’on a fait avec Benjamin, mon
associé, lors de cette première vague.
On a remarqué un réel besoin
des étudiants en période de crise.
On a vu qu'on avait une réelle
mission envers l'éducation.
Et en période de crise,
il faut réussir à innover.
Alors on s’est dévoué, on s’est investi
énormément, on a donné de notre personne
pour essayer de trouver
des concepts inédits.
Certains n’ont pas marché, pas grave,
ça a aidé quelques étudiants.
Et d’autres ont explosé.
Par exemple,
et ça me fait rire d’en parler,
en France, on a été les premiers
à faire des lives sur Instagram.
Ça avait cartonné,
alors que pourtant la qualité
était médiocre, parce que c’était inédit.
Période 2020, certains l’ont connue ici.
Il y avait les oraux qui ont été annulés.
Les étudiants admisseurs dans les écoles
doivent présenter
aux candidats admissibles
les différentes opportunités
de leur école.
Avec l’absence d’oraux,
de visites sur les campus
ce n’était pas possible.
On a donc simplement digitalisé
le concept des admisseurs
qu’on a appelés e-admisseurs.
C’était trouver des étudiants
dans les différentes écoles
pour échanger avec eux
et en savoir davantage sur les écoles.
35% des étudiants 2020 ont fait
leur choix d’école grâce à Mister Prépa.
C’est pourquoi, après le confinement,
on devait faire un choix,
un choix qui était assez complexe :
soit partir dans un cabinet de conseil -
mon rêve était d’intégrer un prestigieux
cabinet de conseil en stratégie -
ou alors m’orienter vers ce chemin
complexe, flou, de l’entrepreneuriat.
Après tous les sacrifices qu’on avait
faits, tout l’engagement qu’on a eu,
on s’est lancé.
Ça y est, on est à temps plein
sur notre projet pendant sept mois.
À ce moment-là,
on rencontre les premières difficultés :
embaucher les premières personnes, trouver
des locaux, structurer notre projet.
Mais on voit que ça cartonne
parce qu’on se donne à fond.
On n’est pas là pour l’argent,
on est là pour la mission.
C’est aussi un enseignement
que j’ai appris :
il ne faut pas entreprendre pour l’argent,
il faut entreprendre pour soi,
pour la mission,
pour le problème à résoudre.
Quelques mois après,
on arrive à engranger
un chiffre d’affaires à six chiffres
alors qu’on était encore étudiants, qu’on
ne connaissait pas la réalité du terrain,
et tout ce qui s’ensuit.
Tout nous est tombé dessus,
mais ce qu’on s’est dit, c’est qu’on ne
va pas se verser un seul euro pour nous.
On ne fait pas ça pour l’argent.
On a donc tout réinvesti pendant deux ans,
de trois manières différentes.
Premièrement, en créant de nouveaux
projets comme Planète Grandes écoles
qui est le média le plus suivi dans
l’enseignement supérieur après l’Étudiant.
On a racheté des plateformes payantes
qu’on a rendues totalement gratuites
pour permettre à tous les étudiants
de se préparer, d’être bons,
d’être ambitieux, audacieux,
sans payer le moindre euro.
Et on a aussi investi
dans des boîtes à impact
auprès de nos collègues entrepreneurs
parce qu’on sait que c’est difficile
de se lancer après la crise.
Mais bon, parallèlement à cela,
tout se développe très bien.
Mais on a quand même des exigences
académiques en tant qu’étudiants,
notamment l’international - ça fait peur.
Ça m’effrayait, d’autant
que je viens d’un milieu très modeste.
Je viens du fin fond de la campagne
vauclusienne - Aubignan.
Personne ne connaît
le mot « grande école »,
ne sait ce qu’est une business school,
et tout ce qui s’ensuit.
Pour moi déjà, Lyon, c’était l’exode.
Alors partir dans un pays, waouh !
Je vais en Suisse, en Belgique,
en Espagne ? C’est génial.
Et je vois qu’EM Lyon avait
un partenariat avec Berkeley,
C’est nouveau, je le vois dans mes mails :
« Waouh ! La nouvelle direction
fait bien son taf ! »
Et je me dis : « Après tout,
Berkeley, c’est quand même
the place to be pour les entrepreneurs.
Et même si je ne suis pas
bon en anglais, why not ?
On y va ? »
C’est parti, je me lance
dans le process hyper sélectif.
Première étape, deuxième étape,
troisième étape, quatrième.
C’est long, mais je commence à y croire.
Juillet 2021,
je reçois ma lettre d’admission.
Dans quelques mois,
je m’envole pour les États-Unis.
C’est génial !
Janvier 2022, mon arrivée en Californie.
J’ai été bluffé par le mindset,
l’ouverture d’esprit,
la vitesse à laquelle tout va.
Berkeley est un autre monde.
J'ai eu des cours avec des prix Nobel.
J'ai rencontré les plus grands
entrepreneurs du monde.
J’ai côtoyé des étudiants
de diverses nationalités.
J’en ai profité pour lancer une
nouvelle entreprise avec ma coloc.
Elle est passionnée de blockchain,
je suis passionné de médias.
On a fusionné nos compétences
et créé « Start in Blockchain »,
* le premier média des États-Unis,
en France,
pour découvrir les métiers et les enjeux
du Web 3 et de la blockchain.
Clairement, je suis au paroxysme
de ma vie entrepreneuriale.
Je m’éclate, à un tel niveau que je fais
quelque chose qui peut paraître insolent,
insultant.
J’ai refusé McKinsey.
Alors que c’était mon rêve
à la base d’intégrer un MBB.
J’ai refusé.
Pourquoi ? Parce que Berkeley,
l’ouverture internationale,
l’expérience internationale
m’a permis de découvrir
qui j’étais, ce que je voulais,
m’a permis de découvrir les autres,
d’avoir une autre vision du monde.
Berkeley m'a permis de grandir, de mûrir
mes projets, de grossir mes ambitions.
Mais attention,
il faut réussir à avoir
l’ambition sans prétention.
Pas facile dans l’entrepreneuriat,
encore moins dans la Silicon Valley.
C’est là où j’ai appris
ma plus grande leçon.
La plus grande richesse,
la plus belle valeur,
c’est de ne pas oublier d’où l’on vient,
d’être fier de qui l’on est,
de ce que l’on a fait.
Il ne faut pas se travestir pour
plaire à qui que ce soit, absolument pas.
Si on n’est pas entrepreneur -
oui, c’est sexy d’être entrepreneur,
d’être en cabinet de conseil en strat -
ce n’est pas grave, on s’en fout,
on est tous entreprenants.
On peut tous faire des choses,
on peut tous prendre des initiatives.
Et c'est parce que la réussite demeure
subjective que tout le monde peut réussir.
Et si, comme l’adage le dit,
tous les chemins mènent à Rome,
alors pourquoi tous les chemins ne nous
mèneraient-ils pas vers la réussite ?
C'est pourquoi il ne faut pas avoir peur.
Il ne faut pas avoir peur d’essayer
de se mettre en danger,
de prendre des risques,
de persévérer dans le chemin choisi.
Chaque chemin est certes semé d'embûches,
mais surtout d'opportunités.
Finalement,
il ne faut pas hésiter, mais oser,
tester,
foncer et surtout croiser les chemins
pour ne rien regretter.
Merci.
(Applaudissements)